the government has a fund called the
shush fund that we pay for folks you and
I pay for this Congress owes taxpayers
answers about his about his harassment
shush fund now what is this some may say
what do you mean by this
since when are members of Congress and
their staff accused of sexual harassment
allowed to hush up and pay off their
accuses from a secret shush fund full of
taxpayer dollars since 1995 it turns out
Congress we all know chooses to exempt
itself from many of the same laws
it voiced on the rest of us it's a
grievance I hear regularly during my
travels around the country as Grassroots
activists complain about the law or debt
regulation if only Congress had to live
under the same laws that we do that get
get it and they change it right if you
go below do you have the list of the
numbers uh robbed you have that list
that you gave us to show exactly what's
in it's on um it's there you go if you
have to list on how much we've paid
every year of the 18.2 million it's on
page uh seven if you go on page seven
and pull it up so people can see this
uh is it on this page it's on the notes
that was sent to us I can take a picture
and send you the screenshot to show it
but this is what it looks like okay if
you don't have it yet and while we're
pulling that up there when you dive into
research on this there is bipartisan
intimidation so when a congressional Aid
or pages are called assistance and you
have promising uh college students from
all backgrounds get a chance go to
Washington work in a congressman or a
senator's office doing this and that and
then all of a sudden you're getting
invitations for stuff and then the
invitations get heavy and then all of a
sudden you're like you know stop
grabbing me and it's literally sexual
harassment well there's a whole system
on this and they on both sides of the
aisle Pat they try to suppress it and
disincentivize people from coming
forward because they don't want any
headlines in Congress and it happens on
both sides of the aisle rob you got that
picture let's take a look at this
so settlements every year since 1997
they came up with us in 95 the shush
fund if you can zoom in a little bit
more so they can see it 1997 it was six
cases settlements at 39 000 then we had
a big year of 16 103
000 you can see that in 2002 there was a
lot of mess going on there 3.974 million
on 10 of them then you go 2007 397 each
yeah I bet one of them was probably a
big one it could have been a bigger name
that we know about 25 at 4 million and
this goes on every year so now
this is a convenient truth on how they
get to protect themselves but you're
eliminating a competitor a potential
opponent so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign